I'm on set today with the very cool and
talented it's my friend talking party
makeup but expect the unexpected
you know what I think party makeup okay
I'm gonna take off the glitter I'm gonna
take out the smoky eye groups eyelid all
on them with my lemon tree yeah exactly
your approach to makeup is very
different it's incredibly artistic my
personal aesthetic is yeah like get that
raw edge I think that's that's what you
should be celebrating they should wear
the makeup not the makeup wearing them
and I think that's often what happens
when you wear 22 products on your face
where are you behind all of those 30
yeah but then again it's just you know
but if that's how you like to wear your
makeup so like slow your makeup when
you're shooting however you approach I'm
obviously I know it's a collaboration
between scientists the art directors at
agra fur and so on but when you think
about the makeup where do you start
makeup referencing is a tricky one
because there's like you know a million
make artists and if you're just looking
at their work you're just gonna do what
they've done so don't look at anywhere
yeah looking my graphic design books
typography people always say you know
let's do stuff that's on trend there are
trends there's a reason for doing things
that are on trend obviously because it
satisfies a desire of what people are
after but you won't do anything new I
feel like it's time for me to find a new
idea a new inspiration the way I'd
approach it would be to look at the
makeup that you're going to put on and
see it as a piece of jewelry and
especially say you're wearing dark
colors or you're wearing black today or
what you can do a pop of color in your
makeup and it won't look so extreme
so what number one this is really really
great just any eye color what color is
that I was I like ovaries yeah exactly
yeah you can kind of blend it as well so
how kind of red that would you were a
black mascara underneath where that
meeting would get enough I just where
you just need yeah you'll see actually
that it's not really that extreme so you
do this before you put shadow on I just
go out with it just on the lation on the
on the eyelid you know what I have like
hazel eyes but I feel a little bit of
green in it yeah and I feel like the
Queen's are bitter for the green nail
you know what I never thought of work
but it looks lovely yes just the hint
let's have a look at the mixer it's
really just about adding a little more
of these red tones into the eye area
this palette for example you've got this
dark opening again which will work very
nicely
really I'm just kind of going over the
mascara and just working it up and go on
the lid as well again and get your
finger involved if you want it's a party
look it's gonna be dark it's gonna get
too much really
yeah I feel like I look more awake as
well as I love a lip stain and these are
really great bits tones they're kissing
blush I mean you can kind of use this
product anywhere but it's great on cheek
because it's just like a cream blush
what would you put on next finish it off
just like a gloss just something kind of
lightweight it's a party so it's nice to
have something with it
you have a smoky eye it's just not what
if your dad is brown smokey right yeah
it's very much very different from what
I would do it's more fresh and glowy
rather than dark and sexy exactly I like
red lipstick is such a beauty classic
especially party time Christmas time a
kind of red red red but there are so
many different reds in twin ways wearing
red what is your method of working it
out I wanted to do something more matte
with you anyway putting them up like
this it's very hot more than the figure
I've never thought that super bright but
we look amazing midsummer whereas these
two kind of aloo to that and kind of
autumnal feelings hate your tush clap
and just around the top of the lip here
highlight that area and also on the
bottom corner of the mouth here this
just adds an extra dimension to your
legs Wow
you can't do it often put your lipstick
on because it would smudge it but if you
do it before then you can go right up to
the edge with your lipstick
I really slow and follow the lines I'm
in lipstick school but it's like that
happens or not the way to get really
good control is to start from the inside
and just work it out okay so we've done
the lips and we're doing brows after now
is that how you would normally do it I
guess if you're going to have a red lip
it's a statement and so if you want to
you know work on your brows it's
important to get the balance you're
gonna be using all those brow mascara
yeah I yeah I think they're so easy they
are and actually what's amazing about
them is you can brush them into your
eyebrow and then blend them in very
slightly as well so I kind of start from
the middle and brush it out like this so
I'm basically back combing the product
into the eyes I have totally done the
opposite
honest and scientists feel like those
cool French girls because they're bushy
brows and we're red lit and I kind of
thrown on Isis your little bear perfect
do you think that you'd wear this kind
of look out I know you said you didn't
really worry about it genuinely I work I
really love it
I would have never thought it was
wearing with a brow so thank you so much
about it great and I'm definitely
inspired me and I think everyone who's
watching
you